we just started talking about the tbs
years of conan and so we thought who
better than to help us with that
transition than
the man who played ted turner on so many
conan sketches
oh yeah that was a fun experience you
forgot you played the character you just
i feel like we just reminded you oh yeah
yeah yeah
i think i feel like the first time i did
it was one of the first shows right it
was it was i think the first week i
think so pretty early on yes i found out
i talked to matt o'brien who created you
know the turner character with you oh
yeah he was amazing yeah he's great i
didn't do anything i would just come in
and say the words he
he was great collaborative process mr
turner i just want to say it's a real
honor to have you here well i'm glad
you're honored i am horrified
right when i left tbs it was a premier
entertainment destination now they hired
some freckled rooster on stills to
destroy it yeah he reminded me i forgot
that we rehearsed it he had height went
out and hired somebody to give it a try
and it didn't go that well in rehearsal
and then i i think he had seen you in a
sketch on snl playing zell miller and he
thought oh you'd be great playing this
kind of southern
sassy guy
that makes sense we were so excited when
you said yes because we're like oh he's
not going to we just thought you'd be
too busy to do it so we were very
excited was it the buffalo that
convinced you but that that certainly
had something to do with it what are you
people looking at
never seen a man on a bubble
no i was if i remember correctly the
timeline
this was in the period after right after
i had left snl the first couple years
after that and so i was uh i didn't
really have a lot going on i was just
hanging around
not really doing anything you were just
at warner brothers wandering around yeah
yeah
hey
[Laughter]
yeah and then off and on again for a
couple years there's a compilation of
you on all the times you did it and it's
like 45 minutes long so you did it many
many times oh really oh my god oh man i
know i did it i did it in a couple
different locations i remember new york
very specifically and i feel like i did
it in atlanta also right were you guys
yes yeah you were great you flew in from
la to new york to do it at the beacon
theater that was the most fun that that
one was that was exciting people went
nuts people were going nuts over
everything those audiences yes for the
entire shows were just like super
energized from start to finish yeah when
we go to other cities i think also as of
our first time back in new york since um
he had stopped doing late night so i
think the new york crowd was kind of
extra excited yeah and then when you you
came down that long aisle on the on the
buffalo yeah the place went insane and
you participated in the first gay
wedding on ever done on television i
forgot about that so did i matt reminded
me of that too i totally forgot about
that that's right okay well i'm happy
about that yeah conan performed um a
wedding for our uh costume designer
scott it was a real ceremony conan got
you you know became a uh oh my god
there's ants crawling up the wall in my
oh my god
animal heavy episode salvador dali
uh conan became an online minister
officiated the sweating on the air and
then they left the theater on your the
back of your buffalo with you oh that's
crazy oh okay i do remember that
they are now going yeah ride off
into the sunset with a little help from
our good friend ted turner take it away
i love that that's like oh yeah right
right what a fun experience just every
step of the way was always
just you guys made it so easy for me i
mean matt o'brien he he just was so good
at writing those things it was just
always fun to come in and and then i
didn't have to
be super i get very nervous about stuff
so so that this was one of the rare
times i could come in and just be pretty
relaxed and know i was going to have fun
okay yeah well it's a fun person to do
an impression of because it's not
someone i think people
it doesn't have to be spot on like you
can kind of just those are the only
impersonations i know how to do
non-spot-on
because no one really knows that much
about what ted turner sounds like so
right not in a long time yes you're in
the area in the hey did ted did you ever
hear anything about like ted turner ever
seen it and
getting back to you in any way about it
or never heard anything
once he sold tbs he was like i'm done
with television well tbs never really
seemed to have any notes i mean i don't
know if that was part of conan's deal
coming onto it but there were never like
network notes no none then right none
that i ever heard